(uptempo music)
- Where are on Earth
is Dana and Julia?
- [Girls] Ew, it's The
Learning Zone lesbos.
The boys bathroom
is down the hall.
Get out!
(groans)
Biatches!
- [Girls] Ham bump!
(door closing)
- Dana, what's lesbos mean?
- My dad told me it means
pretty woman in Spanish.
- Good.
They're just
jealous that we take
the breast Instagram pictures
in the whole wide world.
- Yeah, we do.
- Will boys ever like us?
- Boys are gonna love us as soon
as our bodies start developing.
- But if we get implants,
our nipples will
be out to China.
- Show me your vagina!
(laughing)
(kissing)
- Is your dad still mad
you pinched his balls?
- Yeah, I'm still punished,
but I saw him in the shower
this morning totally naked.
- Sick!
- I know!
All I saw was hair.
My dad must have a small peener.
- No fair!
I haven't seen my
dad's pork sword.
God dammit!
I have to pee.
(wiggling handle)
Dana, someone's in there.
(kicking door)
Ew! Michael Jackson!
- Get 'er done!
Julia needs to go!
- Aye, you guys,
you want to come
to my cousin's kiss-a-nera?
It's gone be off the chain!
My uncle gone be there
and he gone tackle people
and free donkey ride.
He-he-he.
- Stop trying to
get inside people!
(groaning)
- I'm crownin'.
I guess it's better out than in.
- [Girls] Ew!
- Push harder!
- I can't hold it!
(screaming)
- Julia, looks like you're
gonna have to use the urinal.
- No, that's gross.
- Come on, barbie!
Let's go potty.
- Farting!
(farting)
- Alright.
(tissue rolling)
Oh, no, now I have pee fright.
- This will help.
(water running)
(water splashing)
Oh, poo, now I have to pee.
I'll pee with you.
(blowing breath)
(urinating)
(laughing)
- Dana and Julia,
what are you doing in
the boy's bathroom?
Oh, no.
Y'all gone get yo' little
tinkle boxes dirty.
- Sorry, Ms. Klitnick.
The means girls kicked us
out of the girl's bathroom.
- (mumbling) Not again!
- Oh!
Does anybody have a
moist tissue wipe?
- Oh, (mumbles)!
Aw, little sweetie.
You took everything off.
- Ms. Klitnick,
will you please
pass me my outfit?
(laughing)
- Oh, it just got
chilly in here.
Okay, everyone, back
to The Learning Zone,
so we can practice
drawing our circles.
(rumbling)
(groaning)
(farting)
- Nasty!
(laughing)
- [Girls] Ham bump!
♪ Girl I wanna do it
♪ Don't you wanna do it
♪ Can we do it
(uptempo music)